bonjour à tous je vous propose ce matin
d'écouté l'examen de la proposition de
loi de lutte contre la prostitution une
proposition de loi qui a été adopté hier
soir par les sénateurs et qui avait déjà
été votée par l'assemblée nationale
alors à noter que les sénateurs ont
notamment rétabli le délit de racolage
public
ils ont par ailleurs supprimer la notion
de pénalisation du client
une notion qui avait déjà été supprimée
par la commission spéciale du sénat
par ailleurs les sénateurs ont adopté un
amendement qui permet un blocage des
sites internet utilisés par les réseaux
de proxénétisme
voilà tout de suite donc direction
l'hémicycle la séance est reprise
ce
monsieur vial
même surprise qui vous est proposé c'est
peut-être que l'on puisse se prononcer
sur l'amendement rectifié de madame
jouanno de telle sorte que en fonction
du vote
les deux autres tomberait bien si j'ai
bien compris vous demander de la
priorité sur l'amendement 31 rectifié
bis c'est ça merci donc je demande avis
au gouvernement
merci monsieur le président je ne vais
pas répéter ce que j'ai dit il ya
quelques minutes à savoir que nous
connaissons la vie sur la priorité à
madame la ministre
oui merci oui oui mais je j'essaye de
construire mon propos donc je ne
répéterai pas ce que j'ai dit sur
précédemment à savoir que nous
connaissons l'état aujourd'hui de cette
prostitution qui à 97% fait partie des
réseaux de traite humaine avec des
conséquences extrêmement lourdes sur la
santé physique et psychologique des
personnes en situation de prostitution
je note évidemment cet amendement je
tiens à dire qu'il n'est pas
satisfaisant par rapport à l'objectif
proposé par les amendements précédent et
qu'il certes créé une légère avancée
mais qui ne résoudra pas c'est à dire la
capacité est pleine et entière des
moyens qui nous seront données pour
justement lutter efficacement contre les
réseaux et en même temps mettre
permettre justement à ce que
eh bien ces femmes en majorité des
femmes puissent être respectés et encore
une fois je ne suis pas sûr du coup que
le message soit extrêmement clair en
disant que et bien l'achat d'un acte
sexuel est une violence et que l'achat
d'un acte sexuel crée aussi l'entretien
de ces réseaux néanmoins je note une
avancée donc je donnerai un avis du
gouvernement qui est la sagesse
êtes vous d'accord madame la ministre
sur la priorité demandé par monsieur
viol
c'est ce n'est pas un sous-amendement
c'est un amendement rectifié rectifié
bis donc vous donner la priorité oui
bien merci donc l'avis de la commission
je vais donner plutôt si vous permettez
monsieur le président non pas l'avis de
la commission parce qu'on s'est pas
réunie mais mon avis personnel en tant
que rapporteur de la proposition de loi
c'est un avis négatif
madame jouanno sur votre sous-amendement
parce que si on parle de messages qu'est
ce que cela voudrait dire il y aurait
une prostitution sous contrainte qui
serait inacceptable et l'on le client
l'acheteur serait pénalisé et puis il y
aurait une autre prostitution et là il
n'y aurait pas pénalisation peut pas moi
je ne peux pas accepter ça
même si j'entends bien par votre
proposition enfin sous-amendement il est
d'en sortir et je suis d'accord avec
vous pour dire que ce serait difficile
après tout nos heures de discussions
d'en arriver là à la non pénalisation du
client mais non seulement je pense que
le message ne serait pas clair il serait
pas juste non plus pour les personnes
prostituées
et puis je considère que nous en sommes
nous au début de notre examen de
proposition de loi au sénat
et je compte bien sur la navette qui je
l'espère pourra aussi participer à une
clarification tous que c'était un avis
défavorable selon moins bien donc avis
défavorable y at il des explications de
vote
madame gonthier maurin
madame jouanno madame jouanno tout à
l'heure c'était sur l'ordinaire
et là il est rectifiée voilà c'est pour
cela que j'ai demandé l'avis de la
commission madame la ministre avait
donné son avis auparavant
et donc je mets en explications de vote
et je donne la parole à madame gonthier
maurin
oui nous voterons contre cet amendement
rectifier je crois que il faut bien
évidemment pour se faire une opinion
dessus aussi aussi indépendamment de ce
qu'a dit ma collègue laurence cohen tout
à l'heure le replacer dans le contexte
de l'état de ce que nous avons déjà voté
et modifier dans la loi jusqu'à
maintenant c'est à dire quand même la
remise en selle du racolage la remise en
cause de l'automaticité le délai qui
pour l'instant est maintenu un an mais
qu'il a été un poil si je puis
m'exprimer et donc dans ce contexte
l'introduction de la notion de
contrainte résonne comme un pis-aller à
une sorte de compromis et surtout il est
dit il accrédite l'idée comme cela vient
d'être dit qu'il y aurait un pourcentage
un certain pourcentage de prostituées
qui le ferait de gaieté de coeur et sans
contrainte alors que justement le tout
le débat a montré que la plupart d'entre
elles le font sous contrainte de réseaux
de traite et que
d'autres beaucoup d'autres aussi même si
elles sont elles ne sont pas sous
l'effet d'un réseau le fond aussi parce
qu'elles sont contraintes économiquement
d'y avoir recours
encore une fois je ne connais pas une
femme qui ne met pas dit in fine et oui
je oui d'accord je fais ça parce que je
les choisis mais qui quelque part fini
par dire mais quelle mais estime de moi
j'ai même vu des prostituées qui avaient
qu'ils cachaient leurs enfants on a eu
des on a eu des témoignages donc voilà
sur toutes ces raisons écouter de
nouveau votre encontre
merci à madame gonthier maurin
y at il d'autres explications de vote
bien j'ai été saisis donc d'une demande
de scrutin public par le groupe ump sur
l'amendement numéro 31 rectifié bis je
vous rappelle la vie de leurs
rapporteurs de madame le rapporteur qui
est défavorable
l'avis du gouvernement qui est une
sagesse plutôt défavorable si j'ai bien
compris
madame la ministre donc il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques instants
dès le scrutin est ouvert
c'est exact
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 113
sur l'amendement numéro 31 rectifié bis
appelé en priorité nombre de votants 333
nombre de suffrages exprimés 319 pour
l'adoption 14 contre 305
le sénat n'a pas adopté je reviens donc
sur l'amendement numéro 3 rectifié bis
qui avait été présenté par madame cohen
je le mets aux voix
il ya une demande de scrutin public donc
identique sur le 3 rectifié bissessur le
12 rectifiez bis à la demande du groupe
ump
l'avis de la commission je rappelle a
été défavorable l'avis du gouvernement
favorable
il va donc être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 de notre règlement
1 et ouvert
qui
ça ne demande à
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
bien donc voici le résultat du scrutin
numéro 114 sur les amendements
identiques numéro 3 a rectifié bisset
numéro 12 rectifiez bis nombre de
votants 331 nombre de suffrages exprimés
296 pour l'adoption 107 contre 189 le
sénat n'a pas adopté l'article 16 donc
reste supprimer l'article 17 3
amendement faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune un amendement numéro
4 rectifié bis c'est madame laurence
cohen qu'il présente ces deux mois je
sur le s que ça ne tombe pas l'article
17 à partir du moment où l'article 16
est tombée samedi vous vous mettiez si
vous êtes d'accord va c'est pas une
histoire d'être d'accord moi je suis
pour la sensibilisation des clients et
donc un stage de sensibilisation me
semble le bienvenu mais j'ai
l'impression que dans la logique
législatives il ya plus d'objets de deux
mètres mais bon si on le met en le maire
je le défends règlementairement on doit
le met je demande à vis de la commission
oui de manière cohérente avec leur
établissement
la suppression en fin la non
pénalisation du client puisque cet
article était en complément de la
pénalisation donc par cohérence cet
article tombe donc les amendements sont
retirés
d'accord donc il tombe puisque c'est
unanime nous en venons maintenant à
l'article 4 qui avait été précédemment
réservé avec deux amendements identiques
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
on va dire pareil et c'est pour cela
qu'ils avaient été réservés je mets aux
voix l'article 18 qui est pour
qui et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté et j'ai omis de mettre aux
voix l'article 4 qui est pour
c'est les amendements qui sont tombés
qui et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté l'article 19 l'homme il
est supprimé je mets aux voix l'article
20 qui est pour et qui est contre
il s'abstient il est adopté le 21
suppression est maintenu et sur
l'intitulé de la proposition de loi
deux amendements identiques le 5
rectifié madame cohen
écoutez le problème c'est que nous
voulions effectivement modifié
l'intitulé en logique et en cohérence
avec ce qu'on a défendu au niveau de mon
groupe depuis le début c'est à dire la
lutte contre le système prostitutionnel
à partir du moment où ici au sénat la
proposition de loi était carrément
dépecer de son sens en réintroduisant le
délit de racolage et en en eux
réintroduisant pas la pénalisation de
l'acte sexuel tarifé
il était peut-être un peu vain de
maintenir un amendement pour modifier
l'intitulé de la loi parce que les
moyens ne sont pas donnés pour lutter
contre le système prostitutionnel
donc nous retirons notre amendement
merci madame cohen
madame meunier sur le vin rectifié bis
madame blondin
monsieur le président ce qu' il y avait
un parcours de sortie et un projet
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
donc voilà donc il est retiré
madame meunier vous avez demandé la
parole
merci monsieur président dans la mesure
où il n'y a plus de pénalisation du
client dans la mesure on ne peut plus
parler de système prostitutionnel
puisqu'il ya une dualité entre proxénète
et pro personnes prostituées
donc je pense qu'il faut retirer en tout
cas ça a plus lieu d'être bien madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le président ce seront
mes derniers mots je regrette
effectivement que nous puissions changer
le titre de cette loi puisque au final
ce qui ressort des débats et des votes
fait que effectivement ce n'est pas la
lutte contre le système prostitutionnel
mais le statu quo qui est décidé ce soir
nous en avons une analyse précise je l'
ai déjà dit donc mais je tenais aussi à
remercier les unes et les autres de leur
participation au débat mais
malheureusement je regrette que nous
n'ayons pas les outils nécessaires pour
lutter contre le système prostitutionnel
pour permettre justement aux prostituées
de sortir de 2,7
cette situation de violence de
contraintes et mais tout cela se fait
sous les yeux des françaises et des
français
merci merci madame le ministre marc
monnier souhaité une suspension de
séance maximum dix minutes s'il vous
plaît vous l'avez madame meunier
la séance est suspendue pour dix minutes
la séance est reprise
jboss apparent
bien je vais m je vais mettre aux voix
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
y at il des demandes d'explications de
vote
monsieur roquet ravine sa collègue le
groupe rdse regrette que le statu quo
dégagée par la commission spéciale n'est
pas été respectées il s'agissait de mon
équilibre
nous rappellerons une nouvelle fois
comme l'a fait mon collègue à millau
marne elle la discussion générale
plusieurs principes sur lesquels nous
sommes dans notre position tout à la
fois au délit de racolage passif et à la
paupérisation du client le belize le
délit du le bilan du daily record passif
est désastreux
deux ans après sa mise en place et
délits n'en pas régler les problèmes et
qui peu d'années ciblées il ya un jeune
rat contrario c'est un pervers tels que
l'aggravation de la précarité des
personnes prostituées et leurs voisins
des réseaux mafieux il revient value il
est le mieux fallu y aura ceux qui
souhaitaient le conserver retravailler
sa définition
car aujourd'hui l'absence de définition
précise du racolage passif permet
l'arrestation de toute personne soit
seule base du vestimentaire comme cela a
été rappelé c'est double peine qui
touche la victime qui si la prostitution
favorise la stigmatisation des
prostituées la réduction des chiffres de
la constitution ne figure même pas parmi
les bienvenus attendu cette infraction
ainsi le nombre des personnes mises en
cause pour un collage par la police
municipale n'a cessé de baisser depuis
2003 en 2004 3290 personnes prostituées
étaient mises en cause
ceci je passais à 1800 2008 et à 13,42
2009 à paris le tour de défèrement la
cessé de diminuer passant de 38% en 2005
à 0% en 2009 le phénomène n'en ont pas
disparu
ils servent à cacher à ses apparitions
par éloignement des prostituées hors des
centres urbains
il ya sur 20 lancers a diminué à quel
prix si la santé la sécurité constitue
et éditeurs
qui sont ces petits d'être victimes
d'agressions et d'attac voire le
chantage de la part d'individus mal
intentionnés la logique répressive est
un contresens est impossible de rétablir
le délit de racolage passif tout en
créant un accompagnement social et
sanitaire pour les prostituées
auxquelles l'on confère le statut des
deux caps
nous regrettons ainsi que le sénat ait
rétabli d'une courte voix par 76 voix
par an soit 1,2 comme ça se tient
le délit de racolage passif qui a fait
prendre son efficacité c'est une pure
mesure d'affichage en effet pervers
avéré le seul héros a contrario le
maintien de la suppression de
l'appellation des clients des logiques
de paris iv formes lisses à tivat
imitera suède en 99
mais elle n'a pas été suivie d'effets
estérez miraculeux cela a été rappelé
une professeur d'université a même écrit
un article intitulé prostitution
stockholm la ville où le client est
invisible
le raisonnement des abris sioniste est
simple t'as rien la demande c'est abolir
la constitution
si nous partageons l'objectif cette
analyse ne partageons pas pour autant
son essence pour des raisons de bon sens
et de prise en compte de la réalité
la prostitution ne sera pas établie
aboli par ce canal
mais elle sera rendue encore plus
précaire pénaliser les clients c'est
exploser les prostituées ravira la même
manière qu'avec le délit de racolage
passif qui a fait long feu
toutes les associations féministes le
répète et l'inter mais aussi l'ancien
garde des sceaux et sénateur robert
badinter a également souligné devant une
autre commission spéciale et aucun de
ceux-là ne peut être soupçonné de
complaisance avec des réseaux mafieux ou
même de la ive était ce la condition
sociale du client et salutaire de ces
personnes ont péri zélés que le client
est donc très clairement il faut se
donner bonne solution
ça ne marcherait pas on ne décrète pas
la fed la prostitution pas décision
légale il faut mener une politique de
prévention et accompagner du mieux
possible
ceux qui s'y livrent prostituées mais
aussi clients il faut enfin permettra à
ces jeunes femmes et à ces hommes qui se
sortir de la prostitution que la
puissance publique qui les protègent et
soutiennent le groupe rdse
ça lui est certes inégale et
insuffisante
sur le plan des mesures sanitaires et
sociales ainsi que ce pas d'appréhension
alors où la prostitution n'est qu'un
maillon de la longue chaîne la traite
humaine et où la proportion des
personnes étrangères atteint 90% propres
institutions soient publiques
l'abolition de la traite humaine tu
verras ne peut résulter que d'efforts
globaux en matière de coopération
européenne et internationale afin de
tarir les riches fillon de la misère
exploité par la rénovation
enfin un regret on peut parler de la
prostitution des mineurs qui prend des
proportions inquiétantes évidemment
inacceptable et qui n'existerait un
traitement particulier et adapté alors
mes chers collègues au poney tout à la
fois au délit de racolage passif et à la
pénalisation du client
soucieux d'une politique active dead et
le soutien aux prostituées la grande
majorité des membres du rdse
certaines radios sur ce texte proposé à
l'issue des travaux de ce jour un cias
public
merci monsieur ruquier madame cohen
monsieur le président nous nous sommes
au regret au niveau du groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen de dire que nous
allons voter contre cette proposition de
loi parce que comme j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire
elle a été complètement dénaturé en ce
sens où les quatre piliers ne sont plus
présents réellement dans cette
proposition de loi je vous rappelle
qu'il s'agissait de la protection de
l'accompagnement des prostituées
prévention pour sortir de ce système
prostitutionnel lutte contre les réseaux
et puis pénalisation de l'acte tarifs et
donc responsabilisation du client c'est
pour moi et pour nous un rendez vous
manqué qui entérine comme l'a fort
justement dit madame la ministre
un statu quo ce qui n'est pas acceptable
et ce qui à mon sens c'est à notre sens
n'aurait pas dû être le signe donné par
le sénat compte tenu du temps de latence
pour qu'il soit enfin mis à l'ordre du
jour
je pense que c'est d'autant plus
dommageable que les associations
féministes et abolitionniste ont permis
par leur engagement de franchir de
nouvelles étapes c'est à dire que la
prostitution aujourd'hui n'est plus
considéré que
un problème individuel mais vraiment
comme une question sociale sociétale et
politique et donc nous avons raté ce
rendez vous en tant que parlementaire
puisque nous avons fait en sorte qu'il y
ait un espèce de retour en arrière dix
ans en arrière en réintroduisant même à
une voix près mais en réintroduisant la
pénalisation des prostituées en les
considérant comme des criminels puisque
on a réintroduit le délit de racolage et
en refusant de pénaliser l'acte sexuel
tarifé qui reste pour moi un moyen de
responsabiliser le client même si
effectivement à lui tout seul il n'est
pas suffisant et je suis
particulièrement choquée de voir que il
il ya tant de blocage
quant à cette responsabilisation du
client tant d'entêtement à vouloir
considérer que finalement il n'est pas
acteur du système prostitutionnel temps
d'entêtement aussi à ne pas voir
concrètement que la prostitution est une
violence extrême infligées aux femmes
que les prostituées sont majoritairement
entre les mains de réseaux qui sont
extrêmement violent qui draine
énormément d'argent puisque la
prostitution est un marché juteux comme
sont les ventes d'armes et la drogue et
que je trouve que nous n'avons pas été à
la hauteur au niveau du sénat de cette
réalité de cette violence et nous
n'avons pas donné le message qui
s'imposaient et que les prostituées
majoritairement attendait et c'est pour
toutes ces raisons là que je nous ne
pouvons pas voter cette proposition de
loi alors que nous étions en soutien en
renfort à la proposition de loi proposé
par le gouvernement et votées à
l'assemblée nationale je veux réaffirmer
ici parce que il faut bien s'écouter les
uns les autres que j'ai essayé de faire
c'est que la position que je défends
n'est pas une position moralisatrice ni
personnel ni au nom de mon groupe je
trouve que nous
avons pas mis en avant le fait et les
pourtant les études récentes nous
n'avons pas suffisamment pris en compte
que le client de la prostitution c'est
monsieur tout le monde et qui en fait
lui-même est victime d'un formatage
sociale ou la masculinité la virilité
passe par la domination que la société
disent aux clients que le corps n'est
pas une marchandise doit permettre à ses
clients de se responsabiliser
voire à envisager son rapport aux autres
d'une façon différente et certainement
plus libératrices aussi pour lui
pénaliser le client serait donc pour moi
un acte fondateur d'une nouvelle liberté
pour les femmes et les hommes en aidant
à libérer les uns comme les autres du
système prostitutionnel afin d'avancer
sur le chemin d'une société
d'émancipation humaine
donc on est bien loin de choix
moralisateur donc pour toutes ces
raisons pour ce ces rendez vous manqués
au niveau du sénat mon groupe votera
contre cette proposition de loi tel
qu'il nous est présentée aujourd'hui
merci madame cohen madame lepage
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre chers collègues
ce texte est issu d'un long travail
parlementaire commencé en septembre 2010
par les députés danielle bousquet et guy
geoffroy
il a donné lieu à de nombreux débats où
chacun a pu intervenir les personnes
prostituées les associations
spécialisées les pouvoirs publics la
presse les clients et l'ensemble de la
population
et jusqu'à présent il dépassait les
clivages politiques
aujourd'hui le texte lequel nous devons
nous prononcer n'a plus grand chose à
voir avec celui sur lequel nous avons
travaillé et les mots de françois
hollande résonne bien étrangement la
presse je cite la prostitution est une
des expressions les plus frappantes de
ces inégalités et violence qui perdure
dans notre société et dans le monde
si chacun est libre de disposer de son
corps les droits humains et la dignité
humaine sont incompatibles avec le fait
qu'une personne ait le droit de disposer
librement du corps d'une autre personne
parce qu'il a payé en fin de citation
enfin en effet notre assemblée a opéré
un véritable rétropédalage seul est
coupable la personne prostituée
c'est à dire dans près de 90% des cas la
femme exploité par un réseau
international de proxénétisme
le client dont la demande explique
justement l'asservissement de cette
femme et lui blanc comme neige
on marche sur la tête la prostitution
n'est pas le plus vieux métier du monde
comme le répète certain en revanche
c'est bien l'une des activités les plus
violentes du monde
et l'expression de domination multiples
or notre rôle de législateur est un
moyen de pallier autant que faire se
peut les inégalités et les rapports de
domination
je ne puis cautionner une entreprise
d'avilissement de la personne humaine
d'exploitation commerciale de la
précarité de rapports marchands fondé
sur la domination et je me refuse à
assimiler la prostitution à une ultime
liberté des femmes à disposer de leur
corps sordide cache sexe bien utile à
ceux qui ne souhaitent pas de vrai à une
société plus égalitaire et progressiste
n'oublions pas comme le rappelle
françoise héritier que je cite dire que
les femmes ont le droit de se vendre ses
masques et que les hommes ont le droit
de les acheter
je réfute tout autant l'accusation si
commode de mer la morale liberticide la
sexualité de chacun au sein de sa vie
privée a les meilleures raisons d'être
multiples variées originales
dès lors qu'elle est libre et
s'accompagne donc d'un désir partagé
dans ce domaine aussi nous avons droit à
d'autres rapports que se guider par la
loi du plus fort
nous devions vivre un moment important
manifesté la volonté du sénat de
répondre aux aspirations de la société
vous avez pu lire encore hier d'ailleurs
de nombreuses tribus une saignée par des
médecins les associations d aide aux
victimes et de lutte contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes qui
témoignent de la violence intrinsèque de
la prostitution
mais aussi des tribune signée par des
intellectuels des jeunes des mouvements
syndicaux
plus de 200 maires et conseillers
municipaux qui demande une
dépénalisation des prostituées et pardon
et une responsabilisation des clients la
proposition de loi sur laquelle nous
devons nous prononcer et dénaturé et
tourne le dos à la conception française
a poli sioniste vieille de plus de
cinquante ans
les débats se sont focalisés sur la
pénalisation du client
et voilà le navrant résultats par son
adoption nous enverrions un message des
plus rétrogrades à toutes les
prostituées et à nos voisins européens y
compris ceux qui ont fait le choix de la
réglementation et en estime aujourd'hui
le désastreux bilan en terme de
développement des réseaux et de
précarisation des prostituées la mise en
place du parcours de sortie de la
prostitution et la volonté réitérée de
lutter contre les réseaux conduiront
cependant la majorité du groupe
socialiste à s'abstenir
mais à titre personnel je voterai contre
le texte
merci madame lepage
madame meunier président madame la
ministre chers collègues moi aussi j'ai
un goût amer en prononçant ces quelques
mots pour expliquer mon vote je
m'exprime à titre personnel autant je me
réjouissais dans la discussion générale
du vote qui allait se faire
quel est grand dire est qu'ils allaient
nous faire grandir sur une question
difficile certes mais qui comme cela a
été dit participent aux questions
d'égalité entre les femmes et des hommes
donc cela a été dit l'esprit de la loi
qui était équilibré qui avaient un
message clair et précis à la fois
pour les réseaux et les proxénètes pour
les personnes prostituées et pour les
clients
et bien ce soir après les votes qui ont
eu lieu n'est plus du tout dans cet
équilibre
donc j'en suis bien déçu très attristé
et plus que un statut pour moi j'y vois
une régression et un recul qui nous fait
revenir aux années 2003 donc un goût
amer qui me fera ne pas voter ce texte
mais je veux être positive constructive
et je me dis que dans son parcours
le parcours de ce texte première lecture
aussi au sénat tout n'est pas perdu
moi je crois et je veux croire que nos
collègues à l'assemblée nationale
retrouveront le texte originel avec
notre concours
monsieur président de la commission
spéciale car je pense que nous ne
baisserons pas les bras d'une manière ou
d'une autre nous retrouverons contacts
sur ce texte pour le faire progresser
dans l'intérêt général et surtout en
faveur des personnes prostituées parce
que ce que je veux dire aussi c'est que
par nos votes
je doute aussi des mesures et la mise en
oeuvre des mesures que nous avons décidé
pour l'accompagnement et la protection
des personnes prostituées et donc en
cela je ne voterai pas et je voterai
contre ce texte qui sortent de nos
débats hélas ce qui ne reflète pas du
tout le travail effectué depuis ces
derniers mois
merci madame monnier monsieur le
président de la commission spéciale
oui monsieur prise en main ministre mes
chers collègues et sans vouloir allonger
des débats un mot il a été effectivement
exprimé par beaucoup une déception de
voir effectivement le point auquel nous
aboutissons au terme de deux de ces
nombreux échanges
je peux dire d'ailleurs que pour partie
jeu je rejoins même si mon groupe
prendra une position différente les
propos exprimés par mam le rapporteur
puisque lors des nombreux échanges qu'il
y ait eu autant sur la le rétablissement
du décollage que sur la pénalisation du
client
nous avons vu les nombreuses expressions
qui ont été avancées et qui montrent que
de toute évidence malgré le travail
important qui a été fait par la mission
spéciale
nous sommes aujourd'hui sur je dirais
pas une confrontation un d'affrontements
dans des positions différentes
car nous avons vu que sur beaucoup de
points notamment l'essentiel c'est à
dire essayer de à défaut d'éradiquer de
pouvoir s'engager résolument dans la
voie de de l'attaqué des réseaux de ce
que cela représente
il y à du travail devant nous pour
qu'autant sur ce que nous avons soulevés
dans le cas du rétablissement du leader
du délit de racolage pour ça que j'ai
quelques difficultés quand j'entends
parler que ont fait des prostituées et
des criminels les non non non les les
mots les mots ont un sens et en matière
pénale et criminelle celui qui fait un
crime voilà et que je sache le délit
règlages est un délit il faut il faut il
faut donner au mot le sens qu'ils ont
surtout quand on parle d' infraction de
délit et de crime voilà donc je
l'indiquent parce que mais les échanges
je crois ont été de bonne qualité
je vous dis très sincèrement la ministre
il y a
sur beaucoup de mesures d opposition qui
se sont fait non pas tant dans dans le
fond des mesures
que dans la porte et qu'ils étaient
attendus de celles-ci et je crois
qu'effectivement cela il dédie nous
sommes dans un texte qui n'est pas sous
le coup de l'urgence et qui pourra
bénéficier d'un aller retour avec l
assemblée nationale
j'espère que sur beaucoup de points qui
ont été évoquées ce soir et sur lesquels
nous avons vu leurs insuffisances valeur
faiblesse nous pourrons progresser
cela étant c'est une étape et donc le
groupe ump se prononcera favorablement à
ce texte
en espérant que les débats qui suivront
y compris pourquoi ne pas envisager des
discussions avec l'assemblée nationale
sur un sujet aussi fondamental qui est
celui de l'honneur de la condition
humaine sur lequel il faut que nous
puissions avancer ensemble
merci monsieur le président y at il
d'autres explications madame benbassa
merci monsieur le président ce texte de
loi s'étant trompé de cible dès le début
a fini sous une forme prohibitionniste
c'était son sort si nous voulons aider à
l'émancipation des femmes
il faut leur donner la possibilité de le
faire en s'attaquant par exemple avec
vigueur aux réseaux en investissant des
fonds suffisants pour aider celles qui
veulent sortir de la platitude
prostitution et en prévoyant en amont
l'éducation des jeunes à l'égalité
femmes hommes et surtout en faisant de
sorte que les inégalités sociales
n'aboutisse pas à l'exercice de la
prostitution ni la répression ni la
vertu comme vous le savez n'ont jamais
réglé la question de la pauvreté ni de
la misère mon groupe ne votera pas ce
texte détricoter merci merci madame
benbassa madame jouanno merci monsieur
le président écoute et j'avais beaucoup
d'espoir quand nous avons commencé ce
débat parce que le ton du débat a été
globalement
extrêmement respectueux parce que il me
semblait que tout le monde partage et la
vision de la prostitution telle qu'elle
s'exerce aujourd'hui c'est à dire en
très grande majorité
le fait de personnes qui sont des
victimes mais pas des coupables tout le
monde le disait en tout cas une main sur
le coeur c'est sûr j'ai été plutôt
consensuel et constructive alors je vais
pas le rester très longtemps parce que
mon sentiment à l'issue de ce débat
c'est quand même une énorme amertume et
une énorme tristesse
c'est vraiment une occasion ratée pour
le sénat et c'est vraiment un message à
contre-courant et la société et de la
réalité de la prostitution
les personnes prostituées sont toujours
présumés coupables elles le sont par le
délit de racolage
il ya le fond par exemple par le fait
que pour une autorisation de séjour
quand même ça reste toujours au libre
arbitre du préfet les clients sont
présumés coupables de rien ni de
complicité
les clients seraient toujours
effectivement parés de leurs vertus
alors oui on peut faire tout ce qu'on
veut en termes d'éducation à l'égalité
mais si on laisse se développer ce
message sur la prostitution comme une
fatalité à laquelle il faudrait se
résoudre on laisse se développer un
message d'inégalités et quand tu vois la
banalisation avec laquelle la
prostitution se développe aujourd'hui
avec une forme de néo romantisme
je me dis que nous avons bien du chemin
à faire et madame esther benbassa vous
pouvez râler toujours est il que quand
on met en scène la prostitution pour
faire un défilé de mode
il me semble que c'est un très mauvais
message que nous envoyons à la société
est en tout cas c'est pas cette société
que je veux pour nous donc non je suis
déçu très déçu je voterai contre ce
texte
dans notre groupe on fait du tricolore
mais moi je voterai contre ce texte
merci madame jouanno
madame la ministre merci monsieur le
président
les derniers mots pour résumer la
situation de ce texte à l'issue des
débats
eh bien les prostituées sont toujours
des personnes délinquante
le client est toujours roi les réseaux
ont de belles heures devant eux
malgré le travail acharné de nos forces
de l'ordre et aussi de nos représentants
de la justice
quant au gouvernement eh bien ils
continuent à travailler ils continuent à
travailler auprès des associations que
je tiens à saluer ce soir ces
associations qui vont continuer à faire
un travail difficile avec des personnes
qui ont peur qu'ils se cachent et qui ne
pourront pas dans ces conditions
et parce que le statu quo a été décidé
encore ce soir ne pourront pas
bénéficier avec les meilleurs
les meilleures dispositions même de ce
que vous avez voté dans les avancées
d'accompagnement en termes sanitaires et
sociales donc je remercie permettez moi
aussi de remercier et bien l'ami prof à
mes côtés qui travaille aussi sur ces
questions et encore un salut aux
associations merci de ces débats est en
tous les cas c'est bientôt une nouvelle
lecture à l'assemblée nationale
j'imagine avec de nouvelles avancées
merci madame la ministre je mets donc
aux voix l'ensemble de la proposition de
loi dont la commission spéciale ainsi
rédigé l'intitulé proposition de loi
visant à la lutte contre la traite des
êtres humains à des fins d'exploitation
sexuelle contre le proxénétisme et et
pour l'accompagnement des personnes
prostituées
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe ump sur l'ensemble
de la proposition de loi
il va donc être procédé au scrutin
public
le scrutin est ouvert
shi
le quelqu'un qui souhaite encore exprimé
un vote non le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin
numéro 115 sur l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi
nombre de votants 335 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 209 pour l'adoption
165 contre 44
le sénat a adopté voilà vous êtes donc
pu suivre
l'examen puis le vote de la proposition
de loi de lutte contre le système
prostitutionnel
une proposition de loi qui a été donc
voté hier soir par les sénateurs
très bonne suite de programmes sur
public sénat